let's talk about let's just jump to this
uh story actually let's let's do this
story right here check this out welcome
to the future my friends from
timcast.com google to begin suggesting
inclusive language corrections for
writers using docs i've already noticed
stuff like this all right google docs
i'm actually very happy about this
because
the aim of the new assistive writing
function will be able to help users
avoid politically incorrect language
quote potentially discriminatory or
inappropriate language will be flagged
along with suggestions on how to make
your writing more inclusive and
appropriate for your audience
incredible there's a reason i still use
notepad
man
well i gotta say i'm actually happy
about this because it will let me know
that there are more offensive ways to
say what i'm currently saying like if i
didn't even realize a phrase was
something people consider to be
upsetting google will now alert me to
that which i appreciate that so i could
use it more in the document write it
down yeah i didn't realize that oh
there's a no-no phrase there we go i'll
save this one for next time this is the
future though
this is i mean elon musk is what one
inch of pushback against a tidal wave of
just insanity well this is where ian
talking about federated systems being
the future is it like i can't demand
like you know we talk about getting
physical copies of media because
anything that's on cloud services gets
censored to death or just wiped from
their servers like you know think of the
movies and how much they've been
censored from like 30 years ago
you know
i have a synology drive at home where i
just keep any movie i want to keep
that's you know been censored well
here's here's what i find fascinating in
the culture war
uh we don't we don't do blackface like
people do it ironically as a joke but
there's like no one is legitimately just
like doing blackface stupid right not
funny however it used to be culturally
relevant
and so we decided as a society hey this
thing we don't do anymore it's stupid
yeah people don't like it we're gonna
avoid it now as for the comedians who
mock the idea
we don't do that anymore either because
people get cancelled but that's the
interesting point
we're at a point now where
it seems like something happened i think
it was social media where you used to
have the left pulling all of society
slightly leftward as the right just was
being dragged behind everything drifted
to the left
something happened where that chain
between the left and the right snapped
and the left just immediately lunged a
hundred feet forward and the right
stopped moving and just went wait what
well now we're seeing the left go
absolutely insane and they're
determining that things that are still
culturally irrelevant are no longer
culturally acceptable you end up seeing
things like ethan klein he got cancelled
twice now you guys see this again yeah
because he mocked so ethan klein of h3
got uh he lost his sponsors
because he said something about uh gay
people that he wasn't actually
disparaging them he just had an
incorrect thing oh whoa well you can't
actually you can't say that so he loses
his sponsors
he apologized for this and then like a
week or a week and a half later he then
tweets
a mock apology mocking his first apology
so now he's getting flack all over again
as well the point is
he didn't even make a joke about
somebody he made a statement that he
thought was relevant and it turns out
the left had already moved and left him
behind nothing is keeping them from just
going off and going crazy further and
further off into the progressive
distance well that's what zooby says
he's like i'm just a normal guy from
2012. well i have my right wing exactly
so what's happened is
yes things over time become less
culturally acceptable some new things
become culturally acceptable sometimes
we go back a little bit sometimes we go
forward but at this point it's like the
left is changing culture 10 times as
fast as culture normally changed and and
we're standing back being like yo i
don't you guys are nuts you've gone too
far you can't change culture into
thinking men or women and women or men
sorry i mean at that point you know i'm
just going to say it the magic fish is
out of wishes to my theory
things change most quickly when they're
falling apart
maybe maybe the culture is in free fall
so the speed at which we're moving feels
like we're driving fast when actually
it's just
falling apart yeah i mean they're
falling apart but then on the flip side
they're using all sorts of conservative
lingo like triggered and what is it like
patriot takes they're using the word
patriot to claim that they're the
patriots no patriotics is mocking
patriots i know but they're
are they yes like patriot takes means
like a tweet from my patriot they're
mocking you
yeah to be fair well but i think what
you are correct about is that
establishment democrat types have sort
of co-opted the language of patriotism
over the past couple of years
right i mean they talk about
insurrection and like you know that kind
of patriotism and like protecting our
constitution and that's why we need to
go after j6 it's like well the purpose
of calling it an insurrection was to try
to disqualify people like marjorie
taylor green and trump right because the
14th amendment specifically says if they
waged insurrection against the united
states so they needed the narrative
first so that people would believe it
then they could file the lawsuits and
try and get it the problem is they move
too fast you you need a generation to
instill an idea that a thing happened
you can't do it in a year and so the
judge in this case
he looks quite the marjorie taylor green
thing where they're trying to disqualify
her the judge looks absolutely you know
it's funny
if you get your news from the left man
these people really warp reality they're
like oh man the judge is face palming oh
it's going so bad for marjorie
the whole time i'm i'm watching this
trial the judge keeps telling the the uh
the lawyer against marjorie he keeps
saying things like what are you doing
where are you going with this
what and and marjorie's lawyers
objecting to everything and the judge
just keeps saying
what are you doing like what is this
about because he's asking irrelevant
things he's like in 2019 did you tweet
this and marge was like yeah he's like
aha and then the lawyer's like how is
this relevant to whether or not on
january 6 in or around she waged
insurrection against the united states
and the judge is like what's the point
of that question it's like is this an hr
meeting i'm trying i'm trying to
establish twist
it's just remarkably bad yeah i mean the
articles of confederacy was a pretty
solid case for the southern states doing
an insurrection i think that's what the
14th amendment was after not because
somebody tweeted that they didn't
believe this election was legitimate or
you know
whatever marjorie taylor green said
something like today is our 1776 and i
think she tweeted that in like 2019 or
something and they're like why would you
say that and she's like because it's
like it's on the state seal like we say
it all the time it's a date that means
like victory and well you saw they
pointed out nancy pelosi said the same
thing like about like the summer riots
that this is our 1776. really yeah of
2020.
that's why i just think it's it's war
and we're looking at right now for the
most part a fifth a fifth generational
war
so
of course they're gonna come out now and
they're gonna bag it's that it's that
quote we say i've never i can never
remember the guy's name that uh you know
it's like when when i am weak or when
i'm strong you ask for free speech
because it's according to your
principles when i am weak i uh or or
it's like you know
whatever when you're in power you deny
my free speech because it's according to
your power when you are weak you demand
free speech because it gives you power
when i am weak i ask for free speech
because it's according to your
principles when i am strong i deny you
your free speech because it's according
to mine right did you guys see the the
part of the uh hearing where the lawyer
asked her if when she said we will not
go quietly into that night whether she
was quoting independence day it's like
what
so what if image she's like no that's
not what it's called because it's not
originally from independence day either
it's an old poem yeah he's like well
that's from independence day right which
is about
the 4th of july it's like it's about an
alien invasion dude i mean it is
fascinating though that he was attacking
marjorie taylor green under the pretext
of the fourth of july 1776 being
bad for the united states it's like
that's our birthday
it's like could you imagine someone
being like today is our birthday what
does that mean are you creating
something new to challenge us
yeah it's ridiculous it is my current
state i get the feeling that it was the
2008 the financial crisis when obama
bailed out fannie mae and freddie mac it
was basically when it sent everything
into a death spiral in this country
fiscally and now people are like there's
no truth but power because money's
useless now well also i want to say if
you think america should deny its
heritage as being a nation which was
built upon
which was built upon resisting
illegitimate power or violation of your
rights aren't you the revolutionary
aren't you the insurrectionist because
aren't you trying to fundamentally
change what this country means and what
it's built upon so the left was smart
about it and seized the institutions
first
now they can claim to be the legitimate
institution
and you as someone who upholds the
constitution are the revolutionary
trying to overthrow
their institutions their institution
that's right you the person who
celebrates the people who literally
founded the country
want to emulate them in some way you're
the person trying to overthrow the
sacred order of the nation i think it's
something the tea party really helped
enlighten americans is about how much
obama really politicized the state
apparatus in this country and turned it
into you know a democrat institution
truly one of the darkest presidents
we've ever had barack obama
and uh he's a guy who politicized
institutions we had federal agencies
going after right-wing groups you had
the
extrajudicial assassination of american
citizens you had the indefinite
detention provisions of the ndaa the
lies on top of lies all with a big
smiling face well george bush junior was
probably worse and with the cheney
actually called the cheney
administration that was pretty at least
there was an opposition to george w bush
i mean
obama is still out there demanding that
any of his critics be silenced and
that's scary yeah the the american
population's response to the obama
presidency was the most disgusting
letdown of my life mm-hmm really yeah
that's why i say you know he's one of
the darkest
uh one of the darkest presidencies of uh
you know one of the most disastrous is
because under this veil of uh uh
like hope and change we got not only the
same thing but many things that were
actually worse
so yeah george w bush was
okay
much darker you know the invasions was
probably some of the darkest days that
we've seen and uh the horrifying things
that came out of all that absolutely
nation building you know for 20 years
barack obama was really really bad
following up but people abandoned the
fight afterwards and that's that that
you know that hit me hard i talk about
it all the time yeah faith in the leader
which was the biggest problem more faith
in yourself i think both administrations
were a disaster for the american people
i do dislike obama and the obama
administration more i'll say that
however you made a point about obama
talking about how people who disagree
with him should be censored one thing
h.w had the decency to do after leaving
the oval office was to go away he went
away and he said i'm gonna go paint my
pictures and spend my life doing that
and we don't hear from him all that
often except for when the left for
whatever bizarre reason wants to uh
march him out and go remember when we
had good republican leadership unlike
these evil maga conservatives we have
now even though they hated him and he
started new wars and was overall a
terrible presence
but then there's the scene where like
obama was in a party with biden and he
looked like he's still the president and
biden is not even vice president and
he's like the mascot or something like
he's just walking around lost while
obama's shaking everybody's hand well
that that
that
that clip is he was looking for someone
so everyone shares i really can't stand
this you don't need to try to make biden
look nuts
so there's a clip of joe biden walking
away from like obama talking with people
and he's looking around all confused
because he was supposed to introduce
someone to the group and he couldn't
find him and it was like 10 seconds of
him being like where'd this guy go
people grab it and they're like oh it's
so sad look joe biden's lost and i'm
like dude come on you just show him
saying trinidad a shabbat a pressure you
don't need to take a clip of him looking
for someone being confused with where
the person went act like he's befuddled
i hear you on that but on the other hand
given his behavior in the past doesn't
it make sense that upon seeing that clip
a person would assume this is cognitive
the problem is when
people on the right
pounce and they don't do their research
i agreed similar about whether or not
shaking hands with a ghost they were
like come on he could have just been
waving no you don't know that he was
actually no he made a deal with the
devil and he was
that i don't want to jump on that that's
the media trying to justify his his
weird behavior it's tough to tell
you don't you don't finish a speech and
then turn to your right and hold your
hand yeah but he might have been like
wait you know he does that thing really
puts his hands up like halfway that
makes no sense can you imagine if you
did that at the end of a tim cast
episode just like turned and like shook
no one's hand and people like what did
tim pool just do can we allow people who
are experiencing that kind of decline
have the power of a podcaster yes the
president of the united states the media
will rush to defense of joe biden when
he does something ridiculous or stupid
and many on the right will rush to say
joe biden to something ridiculous or
stupid with regardless of the context
typically though you don't need to try
very hard that's why i'm like dude like
trump don't make me you don't need to
make me defend the guy you can point out
things you really want to critique him
on and win arguments that way right joe
biden 9 out of 10 times does something
psychotic insane deluded or deranged one
out of ten times it's out of context and
it's like chill on that we don't
need it i'm honestly not even saying
that i'm just saying that
clip showed how like obama just seems
much more in charge of what's happening
in the oval office than joe biden tim
what what was the fake word he said and
it was the one word that describes
america it was just mudder gibberish oh
man so we have to call it that one
i
it was because he was trying to then
change the subject i guess to i was
hiking the himalayas
i was hiking the foothills of the
himalayas that's right thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there